yes Native American uh Heritage cultural
month and um and yes I rolled up on my
boy my boy dreamer uh he does hair he
does hair over in uh in Los Angeles he
does it over off of uh off Ohio Street
in seula and he give Great Cuts man and
and I I rolled up on him once before and
uh and and I love him man he's really
good he's a really compassionate guy and
he was open I mean he was open I I guess
you're always open if you don't have a
real store you just have you know you're
just setting up [__] in in a uh in a
kind of like in a halfway house parking
lot or whatever so yeah but he's yeah he
he he he's open and so I rolled up on
him and I was driving by so I stop right
and I get in the chair I was you I was
first in line or whatever
and and yeah now this time I was in a
hurry I was in a hurry dude and I hate
to be in a hurry when you're when you're
like it's like dude we already you know
I didn't do it but we did some bad
people did bad stuff to Native Americans
bro I'm gonna say it I'm gonna say that
[__] and
uh and you don't want to it's hard to be
like look I got nine you know I sat down
I like dude I got I I'm in a hurry you
know and he just he he he he just gets
real native you know he get he real
drops into the culture sometimes you
know he's just like he's like I am of
the W andot and the
mommy I am of the W andot and the mommy
I'm like I respect that [__] bro but I
got to get these sideburns evened up
Daddy I got I gotta be up the 101 in
eight minutes homie you know uh but yeah
he just he he'll get real native on it
you know he like in the eve of the
Setting
Sun he's just you know he he'll just be
like in the season of The Quiet Moon I'm
like
bro um yes I agree with you but I got a
we go a I need these bangs just a half
inch off these [__] and I'm out you
know he's like in the Valley of the two
rivers like what are you talking about
bro I got a cic or what I got you know I
I just I respect the topography you're
doing but I got to go homie you know do
you take venmo he's like yeah in the eve
of the setting Sky oh you with Sun
Trust whatever it is brother uh yeah I
just I hate I hated that I had to hurry
to hurry
butt um but I respect him man you know I
respect Native Americans I respect
anybody that's doing what they can um
I'm sorry about everything that happened
to Native Americans man I really am that
[__] breaks my heart you know oh and
here we are trying to learn ways to live
off the land again we've gone full
circle I think because we're realizing
some of the patterns of our civilization
doesn't work out some of the patterns
the mythological patterns of uh of
capitalism and of those sorts of things
don't always work out so we're looking
for Solutions now so yeah hug a damn
native brother this holiday season hug a
[__] native baby buy them squash you
know you know buy him a uh
Cornucopia you know buy him a um pork
chop you know get them a get them a
beautiful piece of meat shank you know
but treat treat your native friends well
cuz they are the leaders they are the
champions of time so I'm really grateful
to Ben there and have this cut and
especially them [__] you know back in
the day n they'll they scalp you so
right when I sat down well when I sat
down his [__] had uh his ra his uh truck
battery had died so we had to use my uh
I got a Cherokee I got a Cherokee dude
so we used a Cherokee to um do to jump
start his Clippers so that was good but
it was a little risky too because you
don't I don't know how much you know if
you got 470 volts rolling through a
[__] set of Clippers dog that dude
will you know he'll open up a damn your
occipital if you ain't careful in that
[__] he will damn he'll line you bro
he'll line you up with the Lord baby if
you're not real careful you know so God
that [__] was at a high octave you know
the second he put it on the dogs were
howling you know couple streets over and
[__] and um but we got it done so thank
you dreamer baby thank you I'm grateful
and happy um native Heritage American
month brother it's time we [__] quit
P bullshitting and we let these
[__] loose dog we need to break
into these casinos and let these
[__] loose bro and put them
back on horses and let them take let
them take over this [__] that we're
living in now Native American heritage
month is observed in
November um so that was
beautiful
that